e
e e
good morning everybody it is
901 so let's get started because we have
a lot to discuss here this morning this
is the Monday April 29th edition of the
science technology and energy committee
and we will begin as usual by all rising
and joining representative Kaplan as he
leads us in the pledge of
allegiance to the flag United States of
America to the for which it stands one
nation God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all okay it looks like a light agenda
with only two items on it
a full committee work session starting
right now and then an exec session
starting at 10:30 a.m. or slightly
thereafter but in fact I think this is
going to be a complicated work session
because we have a lot to discuss about
Senate Bill
595 this is a complicated looking bill
but it basically comes down to one thing
and that
is dispute
resolution the reason for the bill is
because today if there's a dispute
between somebody who owns a pole and
somebody who wants to attach to that
pole if there's a dispute about the
contract for
attachment there is a convoluted
process that involves six
different uh factors to try to come to a
resolution of the
dispute these factors however are vague
and
imprecise and essentially mean that
there will never be a just resolution to
this to the
dispute so this bill was introduced to
come up with to replace that six Factor
resolution process with
something better and that something
better is a
Formula based on an FCC formula that's
been in existence for a long
time so this bill wants the department
of energy
to through a stakeholder process
establish what that formula should be
for the
state and and then put it in place so
that in the case of any future dispute
between a pole attachment owner and or a
pole owner and an attachment applicant
that there will be a way to resolve that
dispute that
is uh fully understood actually
works
and gets to a place where the dispute
can be
resolved satisfactorily
that's what this bill wants to
do the problem is we're not sure that we
have the steps to get there based on the
way the bill is
authored now I've been
uh I've been given a series of
questions that I can't really answer and
so I'm going to throw some of these out
find out if members of the committee can
answer
these these
questions questions like how does senate
Bell 595 expedite the pole attachment
process how does SB 595 impact pole
maintenance and
replacement where is the transparency in
the new process since it's non
adjudicatory
does SB
595 shift
costs why is the legislature effectively
eliminating or overriding private
contracts why is the legislature
favoring government mandates for rates
for attachers versus private contracts
between pole owners and
attachments is Senate Bill 595 an
unconstitutional government
taking and believe it or not there's
about a dozen more questions along that
line what these questions reveal to me
is that there's still a lot about this
process that we just
don't
understand we know what it's trying to
do it's trying to come up with a new
process for dispute resolution but does
it do that and does it do it effectively
that is the question so what I would
like to hear from Members who've had a
chance to
study this legislation who've had a
chance to think about it who've had a
chance to talk to people and ask
questions what are your thoughts about
this legislation and is it in a place
where we can move it forward either
today or at some not too distant future
date representative Vice chair Thomas uh
thank you Mr chair
um if you're hearing some of those
questions and talking to just a couple
of people um I know it always seems to
be within our nature to want to fix a
perceived issue we it seems like we uh
as as legislators we we we want to look
at something that that someone brings
forward to us as a potential problem and
I think it's reticent to us to say well
that's not our job I think we can try
and fix it but in this case i' I'm kind
of wondering um after hearing those
questions and you know hearing you speak
uh this has become a very convoluted
Bill
and to what end is this really going to
help the problem I don't know I don't
think I have enough information to know
if this is really going to help the
problem I know we're trying to it seems
like it could but there's some doubt
that it might and
so has the cop
so oh we have copies
oh I'll just take
one sorry
Doug sorry about that like the hen young
of yes I know uh so um so one question I
have is why did it take so long for this
issue even to come up I think the uh uh
this uh current process we had has been
around for like you know several years I
like to hear more about why it took so
long for this come up I also like to
hear
about uh whether this formula really
will help the Pu or not like to hear
more of that from from more
people okay thank you for those comments
representative
muns thank you Mr chair um I um I I I
think that um this bill is um deserving
of real interim study real further study
um I I I spent some time over the
weekend just trying to sort through um
what I understand is going on and if uh
you'll indulge me I'd like to just share
kind of what I what I found um the
um um you know the the Pu established um
some administrative rules it's pu
1300 which is um consistent with the
current stat statute um and the and the
centerpiece of those rules are standards
that the commission uses to um consider
in a case by casee uh I can never
pronounce the word right a judicative
hearing um um and there are specific um
considerations that they need to look at
uh what what this bill would do in a
sense would eliminate those
administrative rules um as I understand
it and replace it with a form formulaic
approach that would apply to all parties
um independent of the
circumstances um the proponents of the
bill argue that it will increase
transparency and predictability and they
also noted that you know we are the only
state New England that does not use the
FCC formula or a version thereof but the
opponents of the bill argue that the on
size fits-all approach has will have
negative impact on their ability to
generate the revenues they need to to
maintain polls um and it could it could
possibly impact their ability to remain
competitive and provide needed services
in the uh areas that they serve which I
think tend to be more remote than than
than not um and and the you know the the
fact is at least from my perspective we
really don't know what the impact is um
you know what we do know is that
uh s SP 595 is supported by the New
England connectivity and
Telecommunications
Association um and included are there in
as members there are breez line Charter
Communications and
Comcast uh they're generally large
multi-state
organizations um those opposed to SB 595
are the new New England or the New
Hampshire telephone Association which
includes Consolidated graned State
communication
TBS dun Barton Brenton Woods and these
are the smaller local or Regional
organizations um it's it's worth noting
that on August 22nd of
2022 Charter Breeze line and Comcast
filed a petition with the Pu for
resolution of a rate dispute against
Consolidated uh regarding annual poll
attachment rates and Joint use charges
um they asked the Pu to resolve the
dispute
uh using the process that's reflected in
the current statute RSA 374
34A on February 17th of
2023 the Pu issued a ruling in its order
number
26 comma
775 that the joint and and the Pu rule
that the joint use charge imposed by
Consolidated is
unreasonable uh and that they should
cease imposing those charges but the but
the Pu also ruled that the petitioners
charter breez line and Comcast did not
meet the burden of proof to demonstrate
that the existing pole attachment rates
charged by Consolidated are either
unjust or unreasonable and therefore the
rate should remain in effect so in a
sense they lost their part of the
petition uh passing s SB
595 would give those petitioners another
bite at the Apple so to speak because it
would replace the criteria that the Pu
used to make their judgment with a with
a formula um and while there may be some
benefits in terms of transparency and
predictability um I at least would feel
better if I had a better sense of what
the impact of the change would be um on
the remaining local providers that will
be affected by this
approach um and you know rather than
rush into this I would rather we
referred this to interim study and at
the same time ask someone the doe the Pu
the affected companies to provide us
with an analysis of what the rates under
this new formula would be um you know
we're hearing that uh the impact would
be minor and and
inconsequential um and we've really
haven't talked a lot about the impact on
rates to eversource Unitil and Liberty
who are large pole owners um and again
we've heard that the the impact on rates
would be minimal but in the words of
Ronald Reagan I'd rather trust but
verify before we jump into something so
um you know I
I it I think it's it's it's it's worthy
of of further study um and I just think
that uh it would be premature to act at
this point and hopefully that has helped
a little bit
thank you representative muns good
comments very helpful yes representative
Harrington just just a little in in way
of background on this this is not a new
issue the pole the pole Wars as where I
guess they would refer to at one time
have been going on for I'm aware of
since at least the early 2000s maybe
before that and a couple of things need
to note originally this was all set up
back in the days when we had basically
two types of companies there was a
regulated telephone company and a
regulated Electric Company both of which
had poles and they allowed things to be
attached but back in the day there was
not many attachments that was before
cable TV and internet and every other
wire that's hanging on there right now
so the world is definitely changed the
other thing we need to be aware of is
that if there's an additional cost or
loss of Revenue or whatever associated
with the polls owned by the telephone
company by the electric companies that's
a charge that they can pass through to
rate payers because of a regulated
utility the telephone companies no
longer fit in that decision they're
basically got to go out and compete in
the market so what they pay if they have
to pay more they're going to have to
raise their rates or or lose profits so
this we got to recognize that there's a
difference between the two uh people
that own the polls and lastly there's a
lot of other issues with polls besides
cost I mean I for example I can give you
one from my town for over a year uh
every weekend when people drive to the
dump you go by a pole that's about 3 ft
long hanging in the air suspended by
wires and no one seems to be able to get
around to put those wires onto the new
telephone pole they just hang there and
everyone keeps saying why don't you get
that fixed well I've tried and no one
seems to want to be able to fix it and
recently now with all these down Poes
over the last couple of weeks in storms
you you see more and more of these and
like I say they can be hanging there for
years they're not electric wires they're
only communication wires the lower ones
on the pole so so there's other issues
associated with this I understand that
the cost issue people want to get
resolved upfront so they especially with
expansion of um internet service I think
there's a lot of federal money for that
uh they want to get this this is fixed
but I just want to let people know that
there it's kind of two separate cases
one for telephone polls that are own by
telephone companies and one for
telephone polls that are own by electric
companies and I'm not sure how we
address that because it's clearly the
financing is clearly different where one
can go to the Pu and say I've got to pay
I'm making less money on my telephone
pole rentals now so I'm going to have to
make up that money someplace else where
the telephone company can only say I'm
making less money on my uh telephone
pole rental so I'm going to have to
raise prices or low lower profits two
different cases I just want people to be
aware of
that thank you I'd remind members that
there are members of both sides of this
um on on this bill here today and I will
allow asking questions
if anybody has questions that they want
to ask representative Thomas thank you
um when the consumer Advocate was uh
testifying on this bill he testified
that he wanted it to go to interim study
and when I asked him specifically why
interm study and not just kill the bill
he noted inconsistency in disputes best
public policy excuse me and have to get
cost allocations correct
um and then when I asked how many poll
disputes have occurred on a yearly basis
I was told there were two cases that
were adjudicated in 12 years so this
this may or may not be a
problem if it is a problem it sounds
like it's a it's a big problem that
we're going to have to look at many
pieces and I don't think going to interm
study at this point in the in the term
is the correct thing I think we should
kill the bill and bring it back next
year in the first year and then take a
good look at
it okay thank you I would like to Echo
representative Bun's comments
that it's really kind of hard to see
what the effect of this change would be
without some numbers I'd like to see
some numbers what's a what's a rate
today what's a rate going to look like
after this change is made we have seen
no information of that sort in this uh
in the runup to this to this bill so far
representative McGee had some
comments thank you Mr chairman I didn't
know you saw me over here um I was just
looking back on some I always see you oh
thank you um so I was just looking back
over some notes and um one of the
concerns that uh folks seem to have is
that we have sort of a diverse market
right we have larger players and then we
have smaller players and and uh and we
we were concerned very much about that
competition and preserving the
competition and not making rules that
would Advance uh you know one provider
versus another um we did have testimony
from New Hampshire telephone Association
and Granite State Communications in
opposition to the bill saying that the
FCC formula already generate uh is
generous uh toward
attachers um and that they were
concerned that they might be shifting to
customers and
um they they basically said that the
existing mechanism for resolving
disputes which is based uh the Pu bases
it on the FCC formula as a starting
point for looking at whether the private
contracts are just and reasonable that
those are working well so you know with
all the other stuff that's been said
already the other question is why do we
need to do this because our Market may
not be the same as as uh some other
markets in New England and again we
don't have that information in order to
apply it get to the decision of whether
we want to pass the
Bill representative
Corman thank you you know as I think
about this you know I think this is
really for when there's a dispute most
of the time everything's done with
private contracts and as representative
Thomas pointed out we've had what two
disputes in 12 years and everything else
apparently has been just settled by
private agreement so that leads me to
think you know it's really not that big
a deal and you know maybe we should just
go with the FCC formula but then you
know they're removing parts so that if
we do make the change if we go say with
the FCC formula then maybe some of the
private agreements don't become private
agreements and they go to adjudication
because one of the parties feels like
they're better off with the FCC
formula um so that's one of the concerns
I have just about the moving parts and
how it it may actually lead to more
adjudications the devil's in the details
as they always say correct it is
possible that the low number of um
disputes that have occurred in the last
12 years is a direct result of the
inadequacy of the current uh six- Factor
test as they call it in resolving
disputes so people don't even bring them
because they know that it's going to be
kind of useless um to bring them forward
so that is a possibility one that I
think needs to be
investigated representative Ms thanks Mr
chairman um you know just following up
on Representatives corman's point I mean
I think there might even be some around
um private
agreements um there might even be some
concern with the way the bill is written
right now that um it could eliminate
these private agreements that the
formula could
suede um a a private agreement um and um
I mean I think that would be something
we'd want to make sure we understood
better representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair um I agree
that there's a lot we we we need to find
out before we can make a decision about
this bill but I I just want to bear in I
want us to bear in mind that uh the at
the end of the day the our constituents
need better service in terms of third
party providers and internet providers
in the state and uh one of the things
that might be holding that back is the
the legal framework around these private
contracts at the present so you know
that we might need some kind of
resolution that isn't apparent just
because we've only had two cases in the
last 12
years representative
parshall thank you chair I says long as
everybody else's way and I thought it
would do the same I'm in full support of
everything that's been said uh sending
this to uh interm study and also the
financial note concerns me we're talking
about one position I realize it's small
dent in our budget but when we have so
many other committees crying out or so
many other do the Department of
Environmental Services like uh
complaining about Staffing shortages I
just think we ought really parse this
before we just jump on the bandwagon for
right-sized government which I do
support representative Harrington yeah
one of the concerns I had on this um was
the very end of the amendment uh on
starting on line 29 when it talks about
well I'll just read the whole thing
within 30 days following the close of
the Department's non- adjudicative
proceeding the commission shall conduct
formal rulemaking to incorporate the
formula developed by the department into
its rules to adopt accelerated so forth
and so on um it appears to say that the
doe is going to come up with rules with
with some type of a proceeding that's
going to come up with some type of
formula they're going to hand it over to
the Pu and say this is the rule uh this
is what we have to do now you must
incorporate this into your rules uh are
we giving the Pu discretion at all it's
not clear to me if they can look at it
and say well we disagree with part of
that and we think there should be
something different so uh I don't I
don't know if that's been clarified is
this that's what you're looking at
before we discuss that specific issue I
just passed out the amendment I hadn't
passed it out earlier here because uh it
hadn't come up yet but since you brought
it up representative Harrington I have
passed out the amendment everyone will
now have a copy of it and can evaluate
um I'm just not the question that
representative Harrington is asking yeah
I'm just not clear what that implies
because I don't think we've this I know
we're breaking new ground with a lot of
this because you know we in the past it
would have been the Pu would have done
the whole shebang on this but now you
have it appears to have the doe coming
up with a policy that they give to the
Pu and say put this into rules and it's
not clear to me if they can look at it
and say well that really doesn't work we
have to make some adjustments or is it
just a you know we going to make we're
going to get your main idea in there but
we can make changes or is it here's the
rules word for word you put here's the
here's the policy put it in the rules
and you have no discretion to make any
changes it's to me it's not clear it's a
new it's a new process
right okay I had not St started a
discussion of the amendment yet because
I thought we were we needed to fully
understand the big picture of the bill
before we got to to that point but since
you've sort of initiated an
investigation a discussion about the
amendment we can now go there and
um so let me just introduce the
amendment by saying that basically what
it does is it adds a new
section a section five that starts on
line 20 and goes through lines
25 that provides an
offramp
to carriers that allows a rate to be
phased in over 10 years at 10% per
year
and is a possible way to deal with some
of these issues but it may not be an
adequate way so that's the introduction
of the amendment and we can discuss it
now or we can continue discussing the
bill from a high level either way
representative buns um I'd just like to
come back to um a point that
representative Kaplan made uh regarding
um deployment of um Broadband I think
that's what you were you were getting at
um and and that was something that we
had heard in in testimony it was
something that I was concerned about
because um the last thing we want to do
is have rates that get in the way of
doing that but I when I was doing my
research over the weekend I I did note
that I did notice that in the current pu
standards the the six Factor tests that
they use one of the tests is the
potential impact on deployment of
broadband services so um I think that at
least is getting some consideration as
part of the current rate setting
process okay who's next representative
Thomas
thank you I'm going to be high here well
high level um sorry um so uh when
eversource was testifying I specifically
asked if they were unhappy with the pole
dispute process prior to the case that
initiated this bill and they said
no so I'm not sure if we're looking for
a solution to a problem that may or may
not
exist representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair so uh as I
understand this bill um I think uh
representative Harrington put his finger
on one of the key issues those uh
regulated utilities like uh eversource
and whatnot um can pass their fees off
for any kind of pole attachment
issues no problem so what really is an
issue here is now independent telephone
companies largely smaller ones having to
deal with uh
applications uh to put Broadband
services on their
polls uh and and those are in generally
less well served areas now because in
well served areas most of those Services
exist so it's largely in the uh in in
the more rural uh communities and the
question is how do you define Define
what is a legitimate cost
for uh that Arena as opposed to the rest
of the Arena out there which you know
the ever sources of the Unitil or
Liberty have have well covered um I I uh
I agree with the chairman that what we
don't know are the costs particularly in
those two areas new Broadband Services
coming into underserved areas and small
electric utilities owning a certain
number of poles um how how does moving
from the six Factor test to the FCC Test
impact uh revenues and and ability to
survive as the pole owning company so I
I think we need to understand that um
what whether that be uh information that
we asked doe to collect or we do an
interim study on I I you know I'm
ambivalent uh but I think that's the
Grist that this bill is really trying to
churn thank you representative McGee
thank you Mr chair um so bring us back
to the uh Amendment and I wanted to draw
our attention to section six uh which is
on line 26 it says the formula shall
exclude from actual capital and non-
capital cost reimbursements from
attaching entities for non-recurring
costs and I looked at that and I'm like
I something may be wrong with me but I
I'm not really sure uh I understand that
we're trying to give guidance here and
that uh we're also uh have an FN on the
original bill because the doe doesn't
really have the subject matter expertise
to make these determinations and so
they're going to have to hire somebody
to help them figure it out so again I'm
really just wondering you know what what
what exercise we're trying to pursue
here uh to follow up really on on uh
representative Wendy Thomas's Point are
we trying to solve something that really
doesn't need solving it's it's it seems
to be in the eye of the beholder right
we've had conflicting testimony on
whether or not this is needed
and representative McGee to follow up on
your comment there what is the
definition of nonrecurring
costs we don't even know what that is
right representative
muns um with with respect to the the
amendment and specifically the Clause
that's being added the new section five
um well I think that's a a noble attempt
to try to to try to soften the impact um
the fact is that um it it's it it
doesn't do anything about the fact that
over the course of uh a specific period
of time those smaller um players are
going to be are going to suffer a net
loss in Revenue that that has to be
replaced um so it it it it gives them a
little bit more time to get adjusted but
um there is going to be a net revenue
loss okay additional comments
all right well let's discuss what our
options are
here it seems to me
that one of our options is interim study
interim study however
implies that you would invest some time
and energy into actually trying to study
the
issue because at the end of the interim
study process you're supposed
to pass judgment on a recommendation and
that recommendation would either be do
not recommend for further legislation or
recommend for further
legislation so interim study is going to
require some some time and
effort
um and I'm not certainly wouldn't argue
that we are incapable of putting in such
time and effort but I just want
everybody to be aware that that would be
Our
obligation another option here it seems
to me and we may want to have a short
discussion about this is to ask the
department of energy to do an
investigation of this issue and we can
provide
them with a substantial list of
questions to
answer so that I would think would be a
potential option here as well the third
option would be to pass the bill as it's
written with or without an amendment and
see what
happens there's a fourth option okay
let's hear the fourth option just kill
it okay kill it that is a fourth option
good
point
um so given those four options
give me some uh idea of what you'd like
to see representative Harrington this is
more of a question I know if you look at
the fiscal note it talks about the Pu
having to hire somebody because let's
face it there's no one there with
telephone expertise anymore they're all
gone um and and to uh put this into
practice but we don't mention anything
about the department of energy I assume
they don't have anybody that's an expert
in telephone poll attachments or
anything to do with telephone because
they're gone as well they never were
there so did is it going to require a
doe if we uh if we pass the bill as it
is or similar to this it requires the
doe to go out and do stuff are they
going to have to hire an outside
consultant for this and if we instead
just give Mista questions and have them
go do stuff are they going to have to
hire an outside consultant to do it as
well I don't see where they have the
resources I don't know maybe from doe
can speak on that but I would think they
would have to go outside of their
present staff and at least hire someone
on a contract
basis would the doe be willing to make
some kind of a comment about that
possibility
without making a commitment certainly
but uh just give us an indication of
what logistically might be involved in
pursuing a doe
investigation thank you so it is true I
can't commit to being able to do it um
if the department did open uh an
investigative proceeding to answer the
questions that you send to us uh we
would most likely have to hire a
consultant to help us sift through that
um
and get as much information as we could
from poll owners um those are entities
that we have jurisdiction over we don't
necessarily have any jurisdiction over
the people who
attach right so no real ability to
compel them to answer questions and
provide us with information
so I I assume some of them would want to
cooperate um to be able to answer those
questions but I don't can't guarantee
that they will and we really have no
mechanism to require them
to okay good representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr shulock for taking my question my
question is whether you're aware of any
problem with the current process as it
is because we've kind of debated back
and forth whether there's a need for
this bill to pass and whether it's a you
know burning need that we have to find a
solution
for I've only heard the same testimony
that you have I worked at the Pu for
years and years and the the number of
poll disputes
were you can count them on one hand
really representative Ms you have a
question for Mr sh yes Mr chair thank
you um thank you for taking my question
um if we were to ask you ask the
department to complete a study how long
would that
take uh that that's really hard to say I
mean we would have to hire a consultant
that process in and of itself is nine
months at the State of New Hampshire 6
to n months you have to leave a RFP out
on the market for eight weeks is the uh
governor and council's preferred time uh
plus there's time to develop the RFP to
um score the RFP to develop the contract
and you know you add that all together
and you're at least 6 months out uh
before you can really begin and then how
long that
takes depends on the cooperation that
you get from the people you don't have
jurisdiction over and what the expert
believes you need to collect for
information so hard to
say representative Kaplan did you have a
question for Mr shulock no I didn't have
a question for Mr shulock I'm just a
comment thank you
did you have another yeah I mean I I can
just say in my comment that if if we did
our own interim study on on the same
issue the um the challenge of getting
hard numbers which is what we'd want to
get would be the same for us as it would
be for the Department of
energy representative Corman thank you
I'm I'm just following up on this new pu
position and it's calling for an
additional full-time
position and I'm wondering why an
additional full-time position would be
needed to develop a formula that then is
used and we still need to actually have
this person on staff after that this
seems like much more than necessary why
not just hire a
consultant I don't know the answer to
that question does anybody
uh who is in attendance here today have
an answer for that
question Mr Beamer who's currently with
the SEC and the puc is shaking his head
he has no
answer misss Weston do you have any uh
answer thank
you good afterno for the record my name
is Mora Weston I represent necta and
I'll have you introduce yourself Sean
thank you thank you Mr chman Sean
Carroll with Comcast and um representing
the interests of necta as
well I gather that you're speaking about
the fiscal
note that yes yes had um that fiscal
note was attached to the bill as
introduced in the Senate that bill
looked very different than the bill in
front of you today and in fact this is
no
longer uh under the um workload or
jurisdiction of the Pu but rather the
department of energy and in the Senate I
believe the department of energy
testified that they have the current
that they have resources currently to be
able to undertake this process and that
the fiscal note is now irrelevant that's
my
understanding okay well that clears that
up thank you
sure and while we're here um
representative McGee had a very specific
question about I believe section six of
the bill and I think Sean can quickly
answer that for
you sure thank you um yeah thank thank
you for the question so um section six
is largely focused on Make Ready costs
which are the costs that a new attacher
pays to get on polls um so those costs
are not where the formula takes into
account a poll owner's maintenance costs
and other costs the the Make Ready costs
which are non-recurring um are are not
in the formula so they are they are
withheld from the formula one onetime
costs to get on the poll um and this
language is actually taken verbatim or
certainly very close from um the federal
FCC regulation on their on their
formula good thank you for that
clarification
representative Harrington uh thank you I
just wanted to follow up on what you
said so that section six the formula
shall exclude so you're talking about
the cost for the carrier to the
communications carrier let's say to
actually physically get somebody in a
truck out in the field and attach their
wire to the pole that cost will not be
in the uh in the formula that that's
correct yeah a new attacher will pay
full Make Ready costs to to get on the
pool and reimburse the poer for all
those costs now okay so I when you I
understand the simple concept would be
why would anyone think let's say Comcast
wants to attach a uh cable line to an
eversource telephone pole why would ever
Source charge them for the uh their cost
to do that but what if there's a
situation where other people's lines
have to be moved who pays for that cost
that's a new attacher as well any cost
incurred by by the pole owner or any
existing attacher the new attacher will
reimburse all those costs so those are
outside of the formula then that's
correct yeah okay thank you
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for for taking my
question uh we have the the notion that
this is about dispute arbitration um but
I'm just curious about the background in
terms of the penetration of third- party
providers in our state as opposed to
neighboring states and whether the legal
framework that we're talking about here
has had a role in in in m in making a
difference uh between us and our
neighboring states in terms of
penetration of broadband say do you have
an idea about that yeah thank you for
the question um I think theoretically it
could I mean when speaking for Comcast
if we're looking to expand a network
into a new municipality new territory
it's largely a an economic question can
we get enough subscribers to cover our
costs for that expansion and baked into
that economic question is recurring pole
attachment costs that we pay annually uh
to the poll owner in those new
municipalities so um I don't know if I
can say directly that has a direct
correlation but certainly at least
indirectly there's a there's an economic
issue there and the higher a pole
attachment rate the less likely that um
that comc I would assume any provider
would expand because it's harder to
recover those construction
costs further questions for these folks
representative McGee yeah um the first
question is around that back to item six
again would it make would it make it
clear in the bill if the intent is to
exclude Make Ready costs if it said that
more specifically I know you said this
language was taken directly from
FCC uh but it does seem a bit convoluted
in terms of what you're trying to get
at I think we could certainly look at
that I'd have to go back to FCC Juris
Prudence on on this regulation see what
else besides Make Ready um that maybe
I'm I'm just not thinking of at the
moment frankly but I think we could
certainly take a look at that make it
can I have a followup of course the
other thing that struck me um as you
were speaking about the costs of trying
to expand is that there seem to be
federal dollars that are pushing for
Broadband everywhere so how does that
play into the calculation of assisting
you when you're trying to expand in an
area where we're trying to get broadband
and there are not as many customers and
not not the kind of density that you
would see in other areas where that cost
benefit analysis would be simple sure
yeah so the there are federal dollars
certainly coming in to to the state and
to all over the country those Grant
programs cover the construction and the
Make Ready they they don't cover the re
recurring uh attachment rental costs um
in perpetuity so um even we we are able
to put bid in that covers or counts for
our construction cost but those bids
don't account for uh these recurring
attachment
fees representative
uh I got it papovich Miller M thank you
chairman and thank you I just wanted to
briefly speak in regards to that section
six um I know that I'm a guest here but
as an engineer and that also had a PA
license um I just want to point out that
that language actually when it comes to
accounting gabig it's as concise and
clear as it can be it's actually very
nicely SP written because it doesn't get
into specific categories what we call
make ready today we could call it by
another term if we start putting those
terms into legislation and then the
terminology changes that could
essentially change what we meant to do
so this is as clean as it gets and I
would suggest is
that we should kind of leave it be
because any tampering with it could have
a lot of unintended consequences thank
you good good point thank you all right
representative Ms um if if I could get
back to the um I think four op four
possible paths that we identified yes um
thank you folks thank you unless you
have something else you would like to
add I do I I think that there are a
couple of questions that were raised um
in your discussion
and particularly having sha here with
his regulatory expertise we might be
able to help address quickly and clarify
um so I'll jump in and I'll ask Sean to
to pick up in the details because he's
our expert um I just want to make clear
that what we're talking about in this
legislation is what happens in the event
of a dispute frankly between uh an a
poll owner and an attacher and with the
Telecom companies they're competitors of
the attachers I think that that's
important to note and you all sort of
talked about how this is a diverse
Market because you have the Telos and
the electrics um so what I want to
mention is that that all supports
frankly the difference to the FCC
formula and Sean has expertise in this
area but I will quote uh an FCC or order
the FCC has stated that the cable rate
formula sets just in reasonable poll
attachment rates because it is designed
in a manner that is fully consistent and
transparent with respect to the
principles of cost causation and
economically efficient pricing is fully
compensatory to the pole owner and can
be applied in a simple expeditious and
unified manner so I just wanted to bring
your attention to that because I believe
that the conversation here
supports uh deference to a formula that
has been determined to be fully
compensatory
Sean thank you and and I'll just add on
the formula it's I heard um the the term
one size fits all earlier and well the
formula itself is a single formula for
all poll owners the inputs to that
formula are very specific to each
individual poll owner and it accounts
for their specific poll inventory their
spef specific poll costs um so it it is
modeled and it is uh specific to each
individual poll owner um and and I heard
in in testimony a gentleman say that
their rates were $4 for uh for
attachments I can pretty confidently say
that speak for Comcast here that we
would not challenge a $4 rate um we're
paying rates for other attachers that
are three four times that um so the the
formula again just
very specific to each individual poll
owner and their inputs and their uh
costs thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh so I'm going back
to a previous comment that was made
earlier this morning to ask you the
question um would this amendment in this
bill in your opinion uh would it result
in
less private
negotiations uh than what there had been
because there's only been two disputes
uh in other words would it create more
would would you have less private
contracts resolved and there for default
to this formula or do you or would you
see no change whatsoever as a result of
of this bill uh thank you for the
question yes so
um most the the vast majority of pole
attachment contracts in this state are
already in existence and have been for
for decades um so we're talking about a
very few new attachment agreements that
are are negotiated today um so we're
really just talking about the rate
itself um and and the formula for for
that rate um and because so when when
Comcast receives a a increased poll
attachment rate we just get an email and
it says here's here's the new rate
there's there's no negotiation there
it's this is it this is your rate take
it take it or leave it basically um
because the the polls are as you know a
monopoly in a in a sense um and we don't
have another way to expand our our plant
or you know provide existing services so
poll owners have the ability to just say
this is the new rate you can dispute it
at the Pu if you'd like but otherwise
this is it it's not a a negotiation in
in the traditional sense by any
means do you know how often those rates
change uh it depends on the the poll
owners certainly but um recent couple
years it's they've been increasing
almost annually more or less so we get
we get 60 days notice of an increase
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you again for taking my question up in
the Pu ruling that uh representative Ms
referred to it seemed like they were
coming down on both sides you know they
didn't really have a clear view is that
some for one side and some for the other
side it wasn't a very clear decision
which suggests to me that they were
lacking some of the same information
that we we might be lacking uh and that
might be because of their power to
compel uh the the uh the the parties to
provide the information does it seems
like that might be one of the issues so
uh my question is if in this FCC formula
the would do do the parties have to
provide the information to the FCC or or
to or is the Pu running that proceeding
and would they have the power to get the
information to to make that decision
based on the form on the FCC
formula sure thanks for the question yes
uh as as written the the bill would give
the Pu that authority to require that
information those inputs that I spoke
about earlier um into the formula so um
the answer is is yes and I would just
add to some ear comments about why did
why did it take so long to to get to
that dispute um and the answer to that
is there are few answers but one is
because as attachers we did not have
access to that information we we still
don't largely in many cases um but there
was a a separate docket at the Pu
related to the the poll transfer um from
Consolidated to eversource and in that
docket the Pu asked for some of this
relevant information and so then when we
finally were able to see that we said
well based on these costs we're paying
way too much um on these rates and so
that's why we we just didn't know how
much we felt we were overpaying until we
saw that
information okay I want to thanks the
two of you for um coming up and and
speaking to us and answering our
questions representative Thomas thank
you Mr chair um I'm just again looking
at my notes and the lawyer from Granite
State Communications and I don't have
the name of that person um mentioned two
items in particular that the formula
could become standard and not the
fallback uh which was a concern and that
it could hinder and hamper
negotiations I'm just just from my notes
just putting that out there okay thank
you representative Ms so uh back back to
the four four options um um you know I
know I had suggested interm study but if
we're going to do interim study um we're
going to need input um and you know with
all due respect to the members of this
committee I don't think we have the
expertise to evaluate you know the the
rates um we would need some input from
the doe or the
Pu um and that was certainly what I was
envisioning if we went if we did interim
study is getting somebody to give us
some information
if as we heard it's going to take you
know 9 months to even identify a
resource then um it doesn't seem to make
sense that we would do interim study uh
I mean maybe we can do we can craft
something
that said if we think that this is an
important enough issue craft something
that gives the doe the resources that
they need to produce a study that gets
sent to the legislature by June next
year or something
um yeah you know
that an interim study without any kind
of resource to give us information is
really not going to be
meaningful if I may respond to that um
and actually I'll ask I'll ask Sean to
to respond to that because I think that
the doe would undertake much of that
analysis in uh the r making process
Sean yeah I I think as written the the
the bill largely contemplates the doe
doing some of that analysis it's it the
bill says that doe shall give difference
to the FCC formula and kind of look to
it first but all of the the cost data
that that we're talking about in and the
the information we really haven't seen
yet the doe should be able to get that
in this proceeding that's contemplated
in the bill Mr chair could I respond to
that yes go ahead
month thank you for clarifying that the
the concern that I guess I would have is
uh passing this
bill um and then having that analysis
done um because I think the ESS I mean I
I think that the concern that I have
with with the bill is that it would it
essentially would
replace you know the the the um the
procedures that are in place with the
Pu currently and so what I'm suggesting
is before we make that decision that
that's what we want to do it would be
worthwhile to understand what the impact
would be so that's the
difference are there additional
questions for these
folks representative Harrington I
actually have a question for somebody
else and oh somebody else okay no I
think he's thank you very much for for
coming forward we appreciate it I've
actually had a request from my vice
chair
to hear from the a representative of the
rural carriers there's some questions
that we want to ask of the rural qu
carriers so if we could have
someone is
Rosenberger and um
company Teresa Rosenberger representing
the the Hampshire telephone Association
I work for brn Shure this is Paul
Phillips he's the attorney that
represents the the telephone Association
any any legal M matters he's with
Premier Piper so we're not okay Vice
chair Thomas has questions for you happy
to answer question thank you thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
it appears that this amendment um one of
the cruxes of the of the amendment is in
section five regarding the 10% decrease
over a certain year period seems to be
directed to try and help out the small
rural carriers so I would like to get
your your sense of opinion on if this
section if you feel this section
mitigates your your concerns or not I'll
speak first then I'll let Paul I'd first
say this doesn't cover all of the nhta
members it only covers a couple because
we do have members who have more than
polls I mean 15 excuse me 15,000 polls
um and my other comment would be
secondly it's still puts the original
bill in place which we have lots of
problems with lots of questions about uh
but it just spreads it out and the way I
read it it's retroactive which is even
to me more of an issue for um the small
carriers because as you see it's January
2024 are the rates but it takes effect
on the effective date of the bill and as
I see effective date is July 1
24 so it seems to me it's retroactive
and it doesn't cover everybody but
Paul yeah thanks Teresa um so we've
heard from our clients and they're not
in favor of the amendment um they
appreciate the uh recognition they
appreciate the uh opportunity or the
attempt to um um mitigate the the size
disparity if you will between the some
of the players you've heard from and the
carriers that we represent which are
smaller carriers um what you've heard
today are some
um hints of what's really going on but
the not the full story and you know what
what you've heard is that there was a
litigation at the Pu
involving um Comcast and the other cable
carriers versus Consolidated and that
came out in a way that was sort of a
mixed decision uh and the impact of the
decision on on the cable carriers is why
this legislation is here today um you
also heard from Comcast just now that
there was another proceeding involving
uh consolid ated and eversource
involving the sale of the Consolidated
polls and what's interesting there is
that Consolidated has effectively
divested itself of most of its polls uh
and so the impact of this legislation
will fall much less harshly on
Consolidated because they're no longer
you know a large pole owner uh but it
will fall on the smaller carriers who
still are pole owners but they weren't
involved in either either one of those
sets of litigation so they're
essentially cleaning up the mess here
from uh the large players having
litigated their disputes and come to
some resolution and so so if I could
just interrupt you for a second um
rather than have you restate the
testimony you gave us earlier maybe we
could just um answer questions sure in
the interest of time because we do have
another bill that we would like to
discuss before the end of the work
session and then we're going to have to
go into exec session pretty soon after
that so understood thank you questions
representative
Harrington um regarding that section
five I'm reading this with the it it
makes an assumption and the assumption
is that the rates being charged now are
going to be higher than the rates that
would come out of this formula by the
thing that says you can you can reduce
the rate by 10% a year until it matches
that rate so is it safe to assume then
that whatever is being charged now is
more than would be the charge if you put
put use the formula according to the
bill and one and two how is the pole
owner going to make up for that loss
Revenue right we read the amendment the
same way representative Harrington and
uh one response we got back from our
clients was that they don't know what
rate the formula will produce um we've
heard that it's going to be you know
like the FCC formula or closer to the
FCC formula but one thing we know from
the bill is that it's not the FCC
formula and so um the amendment presumes
that whatever the formula rate is will
be lower than what the contract rate is
uh we don't have any enough information
to know that for sure if in fact though
the rates are lower under the
formula those costs would come out of
the pole owners uh wallet if you will
and then have to make up those costs
somewhere else
followup go ahead uh um okay so you're
saying that the contracts that are in
effect now are you reading this bill to
say that they would become null in void
and new cont new rates would have to be
negotiated using the formula for for
poll attachments that have already been
made and in place or would this be just
only going forward on new pole
attachments I would say you've just
identified one of the issues we have
with the bill there's no Clarity in it
and so we don't really know um I also
would say when you talk about you're
right that when you read this amendment
it assumes the rates are going down I
don't know whether ever source is here
but I know when I ran fearo our rates
were a lot lower than eversource and as
I understand it eversource rates are
somewhat built on the
FCC um I do know from that settlement or
the the F excuse me the Pu case with
with the cables and
Consolidated they were looking to cut
the rates in half for Consolidated now
back to the basic issue here just I
think is the heart of what you're
talking about what does that mean that
means less money for in that case
Consolidated for deployment and as you
know when they got money from the feds
they put in $25 million of their own to
match it might actually I might be wrong
it might be higher than that but to
match the 40 million of the feds I mean
with Federal the arpa money so that
means less money for them as far as as
deployment um it also means the costs
are higher what does this mean to uh
replacement of polls and maintenance of
poles I don't know frankly how Mr ran at
Grant State maintains his polls because
I think Comcast was absolutely right
they're not going to challenge him he's
at $4 doll and which is why they've
totally totally overbuilt his district
his territory and they seem to have had
no problem with getting owned the polls
and attaching to the poll so but this is
clearly targeted those who are um above
that I don't know why Mr ran hadn't
raised his rates to tell you the truth
but I think you see the gist of it with
what Comcast
testified they won't build un left they
enough subscribers that means they're
taking from those who have subscribers
now how do they get there they get there
by lowering their cost and raising the
cost of the competition so um and they
you heard them say they don't want to
pay for the maintenance so it means the
competitor who's the poll owner like
Grant State who does offer Broadband
they've got to pay for the maintenance
as well so there's just so many issues
in this that I think as a state we need
to know because every time I've been
here when I was at cons fearo or
representing nhta or Consolidated you
guys have asked about poll replacement
and it's an issue it was an issue when
when FairPoint bought the Verizon
properties I can't remember you remember
uh revertive Harrington I mean we had to
agree to do all these get rid of all
these polls so what's that doing to that
issue I don't know and um so I hope I
answered your question all right
representative muns is going to ask the
final question of this work session
because we have to talk a little bit
about hb45 1 thank you Mr chair m m Mr
Phillips I I don't know if I heard
correctly but did you say that the
formula that would come out of this bill
or that would result as a that would be
a result of this bill would not be the
FCC
formula I did say that representative
mons and the reason I say that is
because the bill does not require the
adoption of the SE of the FCC formula
requires a non- adjudicative process for
the doe to develop a form formula that
will give difference to the FCC formula
but will then introduce additional
factors that are list listed in the bill
that are different from the factors that
the Pu now uses and so we don't know
what the formula will be at the end of
the day uh and you know you're asking us
to estimate costs and revenues and all
that and I'm I guess what I would
respectfully suggest is that we you're
asking us to predict into a void and we
don't know what the outcome of that
process will
be okay with that we're going to end our
work session on Senate Bill 595 and very
briefly
discuss Senate Bill
451 now representative Corman has uh
prepared an
amendment that is slightly different
from the one that I sent to members of
the committee last Friday which is an
amendment that uh I had prepared in
conjunction with the the doe and uh some
other folks and so representative Corman
is going to pass out that Amendment and
it's already passed out
oh oh yes so it is amendment 16
67h and it is uh should be before you so
representative Corman could you tell
us what your Amendment changes from the
amendment that I submitted and then I'll
talk a little bit about the amendment
that I submitted be happy to thank you
Mr chairman uh this is me being pedantic
uh some of you may recall that that at
least a couple of times I requested that
there be something at the beginning of
section uh of RSA 162 H section 7A that
makes it clear that section 7A applies
only to repurposing qualified existing
energy facilities there's the header on
line five of page to that says
application for certificate qualified
existing energy facilities repurposing
but I really want there to be language
it says this section applies only in
those cases so that's what I added and
then I also made sure that it was as
defined in the appropriate place in the
RSA on page one that's the only change
other than that it is identical to the
previous
Amendment okay everybody got that y
anybody have any questions about
it representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair um on page two uh section
J uh you you dropped or2 system
reliability in New Hampshire and I'm
just wondering why that was
dropped
it so in the amendment that I have I
think you're referring to section J that
would have been on page three starting
at
line 13 is that
correct
uh it's uh on your Amendment it is um a
page two lines one uh lines three and
four and the end the end of line four is
missing in the new Amendment on page two
lines one and
two I'm just wondering why it was
dropped that's
all I don't recall why we dropped that
but that was a recommendation from St
stakeholders and the department of
energy
so Mr shulock do you recall why that
section was dropped by any chance
did you come forward I can't quite hear
you thank
you so the language about uh addressing
about system reliability was actually
Department language we put that language
in the bill uh so we didn't request that
it be removed we just didn't object if
that was what was necessary to pass the
Bill okay so I H I had have no memory of
why that got I think dropped uh other
stakeholders Mr
Monahan thank you Mr
shulock thank you you may recall from
the um the work session we had on this
previously there was some confusion in
that section because it said had
originally said the applicant would have
I'm going for memory here would have to
demonstrate issues around health and
safety or system reliability so there
was a whole discussion about did that
say you didn't have to do one or the
other and so because and you may recall
from conversations after that the sense
was that because uh the site valuation
committee law is primarily a land use um
um provision and doesn't necessarily get
in into the electrical liability and
things that's captured in other sections
of state law it was it was best to leave
the health and safety as a
requirement uh and not allow the
applicant to dis not respond to that by
simply saying we're more
reliable representative Thomas thank you
um and thank you for taking my question
um is it correct to say the health and
safety of the state or is it the health
and safety of the residents of the state
well in other parts of the site
evaluation committee law it makes
reference to the health and safety of
the state so we replicated it in this
language thank
you okay that clears that up thank you
appreciate
that all right so the other big uh
change that this amendment makes is
basically in section on page one section
xi- A starting on line five and going
through
line two on page two which is that
section J that uh we were just talking
about so this this is an expanded list
of the components of the definition of
qualified repurposing so that
is basically the major change that was
made to this amendment there was some
language changes that were
made that representative Ms suggested
and he'll remember exactly where they
are so I'm going to ask representative
muns to uh refresh our memory about
those
changes I was I was afraid you were
gonna ask me that
um yeah it's it starts on
um the
change um
yeah it's at the top
of oh yeah yep it's at the bottom of
page four line 30 starts in line
30 uh three yeah 34 or actually 36 and
what it does is it says that if
the there's a requirement that there be
at least one public information session
in each County where the proposed
facility is located the language that
was added says provided that if the
proposed facility is located within a
single city or town the public meeting
will be held within that city or town um
and then that same language is also
added on um in on page
five line 31 and 32
okay and then the um final change that
the amendment makes is on page seven
lines 12 and 13 times for conducting
public hearings and rendering a decision
on the application may be extended for
good cause upon written request of the
applicant and so those are the changes
to the amendment and
um I did entertain any further comments
on the amendment representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair um just looking at my
notes there was some uh concern on the
old Amendment page three lines 33 and 34
with the 180 days that there was a
conflict with the air permits that um
from Dees and I I I noted that that was
a conflict but I have no idea if it was
resolved if we asked Dees if it was an
issue or not
yes representative Harrington brought
that um to our attention and I think
during our discussion we
determined
that it would conform because we we just
passed Senate Bill 449 last week it'll
be a come up before the house on
Thursday which sets the time at 120 days
rather than 80 days
so if the department completes their
applications with 120 days then that
would meet the requirements of this
amendment of 180
days right but does the 180 days
supersede the 120 days can they are they
allowed to push it out to 180 just
because it says it here and not in the
other bill
I'm guessing that would be within the
purview of the SEC to
determine but
um I don't know for sure it's just a
concern that that I noted and I I just
wanted to have resolution to it whether
or not we we resolved it that's
all so Mr shulock and Mr Beamer are
conferring um maybe we'll have a an
answer
shortly representative Harrington yeah I
I think what we did was the original air
permit Bill had 180 days and that was
switched to 120 so it's two processes
here one is for non SEC state agencies
uh Dees Department of Transportation
they have 120 days to get whatever
permits they need issued then the uh SEC
has an additional 60 days for a total of
180 days after the application's been
accepted to issue a deny the their
certificate so it's two different steps
involved and the 120 now matches what's
in the other bill that was changed from
180 to 120 do we need to spell out that
60 days or is that implied in the 180 I
I think it's implied by just looking at
120 and then you go to the0 okay all
right thank you I would I would concur
that that it is implied
there all right I don't see any further
uh questions or comments about this we
can discuss it a little bit more during
the ex session so let's call to a close
for now the work session on Senate Bill
451 it is about uh 10:20 so I'm going to
call a brief
caucus and ask everybody who is not a
member of the
Republican caucus to leave the room we
will return at 10:30 to begin our exec
session and at that that time I will
introduce uh some guests that we have uh
sitting in today for members of the
committee and Democratic caucus can we
just go into the office here because we
don't have a lot of time to go up and
down okay okay thank you see you at
10:30
e
e e
okay we are reassembled please take your
seats and we are here now to do some
executive
sessions and during our little
break we learned of
a previously
unseen problem with the amendment to
Senate Bill
451 the text that was originally sent to
OS contained a sentence that
OS apparently didn't see and forgot to
add to the
amendment
so we are going
to ask uh our committee
researcher Christie
to get on her U favorite hobby horse and
go see OSS and get us another amendment
so chrisy I am sending you right now the
file that contains the amendment text
that we need
what is
he so Mr Monahan could you come forward
please and read the text that OS missed
in their Amendment and explain it to us
please
yes uh I'll read it to you and then talk
about the where it belongs it would be
yeah okay uh it would be I'm working
from the version that was was sent to
Oso on representative
corman's um
amendment chrisy is in aside did you get
the
email thank you it would yeah so it
would at the bottom of page
three currently it is Roman
13 uh um there should have been a
section following that um which re would
read the time to render decision on the
application may be extended by the ageny
of jurisdiction for good cause upon the
written request to the applicant such
extension shall be reported to the
committee so this was to deal with the
situation where if Army Corps of
Engineers or Dees or others had uh
something that came up where they were
not able to meet the deadlines that uh
they could you could essentially stop
the clock uh and as the committee knows
this language went back and forth so we
had something that all agencies of
jurisdiction which would be you know any
permitting agency in the site valuation
committee would have that
Authority so is that not covered by the
text on page seven lines 12 and 13 that
says times for conducting public
hearings and rendering a decision on the
application may be extended for good
cause upon written request of the
applicant that section only applies to
the site evaluation committee what I
just read to you applies to other
agencies of
jurisdiction oh okay that's why the
clarification language orig was
originally proposed yes okay so Christie
could you go get a new Amendment based
on the Corman Amendment
67h that adds that new
section the highlighted section yes yes
and that's a new a new Roman numeral I
believe there' be a EXC me well
representative months and that would be
a new section so it'll be Roman numeral
for uh 14 right yes I believe so Roman
numeral
14 so if uh you can work on that
Christie we would appreciate that and
hopefully we will have a new
Amendment before we get uh to far down
the road here and then we can exact open
an exec session and exec Senate Bill
451 while we wait for
that let's open an exec session on
Senate Bill
595 relative to the rates for poll
attachments
and I'm not going to make a motion
right at the moment because I want to
discuss further our
options when we broke for a caucus a few
minutes
ago our caucus discussed the possibility
of the the four possibility the four
options and we settled on the
one requiring the doe to launch an
investigation into the this process
because there are so many unanswered
questions so that would be
the recommendation that we would likely
like to see go forward so I would like
to hear what other folks might have to
say representative
McGee yes Mr chairman it's uh I guess
great minds think alike because our our
uh deliberations returned a similar uh
discussion and a similar result that we
would prefer to have additional
information but we didn't think interim
study was the right approach and so uh
since doe is charged with going down
this road if we pass the bill as it is
we think it should be handed off to them
and we would prefer to have an amendment
on the bill that does that so that we
can get some more information before we
put it into statutory
language representative Corman thank you
yeah I'm I'm I'm not in complete
agreement with my caucus and and my
reasoning is that when I read the bill
the bill says that the doe is going to
develop a formula and then what we're
talking about is having the doe
investigate which leads to a formula so
why not just have the bill as is and
have the doe come up with a
formula it's a good question but I think
the answer to it is
that the formula isn't the only thing
that needs to be investigated there are
a lot of questions and
we uh discussed some of those questions
earlier in our fairly extensive work
session on this on this
bill
um you know does s SP 595 preempt
federal law will the Pu apply the new
formula is it an an unconstitutional
government
taking
um what is the transparency of the new
process will it be non adjudicatory or
judicatory there's all kinds of
questions here so I think a doe
investigation can maybe address some of
those some of them will be policy
questions and they won't touch those but
they will investigate more uh fact-based
kinds of questions so I think a do doe
investigation could be useful it is
going to be a timec consuming process as
Mr shulock told us during our work
session the application process for uh
hiring a consultant is six months by
itself and then once you get the
consultant hired then you have to start
the whole process get the stakeholders
involved you're you're looking at a
minimum of a year to get this
investigation
done which is unfortunate
but I think it's the best way to go
about it I just don't see a better way
to do it at this point representative Ms
thank you Mr chair I I I I agree with
you I mean um you know if we're going to
consider making a change um we need to
understand what we're what what all the
issues are before we actually change the
language and statute um so I I agree
with you and I and I think it is
something that's worth looking at since
as is has been noted um we are the one
state in New England that um you know
doesn't have a more formulaic approach
and um there may be very good reason for
that um but it's certainly worth taking
a look at before we make any concrete
steps
forward further discussion Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair so um
launching an investigation seems like um
one way to get more information I'm
assuming doe has resources available
within their own Department to do such
an
investigation is would one of the
options
noted in this new Amendment on
requesting to do an investigation would
one of the options be to do nothing at
all that there's that there may be no
problem and therefore they decide that
there is no need for a new new
work good question I suppose that could
be an option is an optional outcome of
the DOA
investigation mechanically if we decide
to go this route what we're going to
have to do today is we're going to have
to recess this executive
session and representative McGee and I
will have to get together and come up
with an amendment that creates this doe
investigation lists the questions that
we think the investigation should
ask and then we will have to come back
here probably a week from today or a
week from tomorrow and resume the
executive session
and deliberate over this new Amendment
so that would be the mechanics of the
process if we decide to go forward with
this with this process chair
representative McGee yeah I'd just like
to say if if we're going to come up with
a list um I think it will start with the
questions but I would I would like to
provide um the outcomes that we're
seeking from them right if we want the
process to be transparent if we want it
to be Equitable if we want want to
minimize the impacts and the cost
shifting that kind of thing I think we
should maybe Define the outcomes so that
um they would have a clear Mandate of
what they needed to solve for and um
hopefully that would help them tailor it
rather than being all over the
place absolutely representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um with this new approach and an
amendment how would that alter the
fiscal note and do we have enough time
to get a new assessment of new fiscal
assessment well I guess one of the
things that representative McGee and I
will have to discuss is whether or not
the amended text
should allow for the hiring of a
consultant obviously that imposes some
costs and so we need to we'll have to
think about that I'm sure everybody
would prefer that we do this without
incurring additional costs if we could
but whether that's possible or not is a
is an open question one we'll have to
resolve representative Harrington yeah I
think the um um representative of the
doe said that they don't have uh
in-house I mean basically the telephone
division from what used to be the Pu is
gone so I don't see that they would have
to they would this is a new type of
thing having them look into telephone
polls um so I I would think they'd have
to have some uh new money to do it or
money to hire a consultant
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
uh just to note that we did hear uh
conflicting testimony from from some of
the parties uh to the effect that the
doe does have the resources and does
have that information available to them
so that's a question that you do need to
resolve all right I think we
representative Thomas and and again I
mean we're talking about a a fair a
fairly large chunk of money uh to hire
somebody for doe assuming they don't
have it and and again this is for two
cases in the last 12 years I mean is
this really coste effective do we
anticipate more
cases well I think it we discussed
during our work session that the POS
there is a possibility there were a few
number of cases in the past 12 years
because the existing dispute resolution
process is
so
ineffective that people just weren't
bringing forward disputes because they
knew that they were not going to be
satisfactorily resolved but is that
hearsay I mean do we have proof of this
I mean i' I've I've heard people say
this but do we have actual proof that
this has
happened well if you think about it the
committee testimony process is all
hearsay so um yes it is hearsay but do
we do do we have to believe it or can we
believe
it you use your best judgment on that
right all right I think we have a path
forward then on cill 595 so I'm going to
recess this executive
session and we'll reschedule its
resumption at a date
certain in the not too distant
future by the way I was negligent a
moment ago
in not
announcing The Replacements that we have
for exact session here this morning so
let me um redress that mistake by
introducing representative James Connor
who's here for representative James
Summers a James for a James as it
were and uh representative Daniel
papovich Mueller is here for John
lewicki who is on vacation and
traveling and
representative Charlie Melvin is here
for representative Janine
nter and representative Timothy Horgan
is here for representative um Noel Henry
Noel so those are our guest
uh guests here today we welcome you all
glad you could be here appreciate you
being here sorry you're not going to be
able to get your teeth into much but as
soon as we get an amendment back from OS
on house bill Senate Bill 451 we will
have an exec on that
bill in the meantime um let's discuss
one other thing that
personally and I think representative
McGee would agree with me is an
extremely important stn discussion and
that is our end of session
lunch so it is
a a custom a tradition that at the end
of the session st& all members of St go
out to lunch together and so we need to
identify a date for our end of session
lunch now we could do it next Monday or
Tuesday when we have our final exec
session it's a logical choice or we
could wait till June and do it someday
one day in June uh as we get closer to
the actual end of the
session so I'd like to hear a discussion
from uh folks here about what they'd
like to see for our end of lunch or end
of session lunch
um representative McGee yeah Mr chair I
was just looking at my calendar and um I
know on Monday the 6th is's a braver
Angels Workshop which is bipartisan
effort that folks go to and that's from
10 to 2 so um that would maybe represent
a conflict for some people who would be
attending that so I just wanted to
mention that um and so if we're going to
do it sooner than later I would
recommend that we try and work in uh
perhaps the
and not the 6th but I have no objection
to waiting until closer to the end date
in early
June other ideas and preferences
representative Ms um I am going to be
out of pocket um next next uh Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday uh but other than
that I'm I'm fine with anything as long
as the chair is
paying that is not part of the tradition
I
but I'll consider
it all right further
comments
okay representative
parial I would thus suggest sooner as
later our calendars as we get toward
summer T to fill up very
quickly
okay so maybe next week maybe the week
after
representative Vice chair Thomas uh yes
just uh I'll I'll be the one organizing
this like I have before in the past so
you any comments uh you can get back to
me on and um we can discuss that plus I
know that
for it's not except for maybe one or two
people I don't see people who have been
here before when we went I think uh cat
you were one yeah uh we we went to a
place called angelinas which is not far
from here at all it was a very good
Italian place but I'm open to other
suggestions a place that can sit
approximately 20 of us and we always
invite our office manager and our
researcher as well and so um any place
like that that would be conducive to a
group like us and who also would be
admissible to separate
chicks yes I was remiss and forgetting
to remind uh or forgetting to request
a venue a location from suggestions from
you as well representative Ms Common
Man the common man oh down the street
Common Man okay that's a good suggestion
Mr chair I was going to say isn't it
also tradition that we treat the staff
they don't pay yes we do we do treat the
staff so be prepared to throw in a few
extra bucks for Carrie and
Christie any other suggestions on a
venue okay we'll leave that up to chair
Vice chair Thomas he always does a great
job on that kind of thing
so all right nothing further to discuss
here so I'm going to call a break and
ask everybody to stay sort of local so
that as soon as the new Amendment for
Senate Bill 451 comes back we can start
and finish our exact session until then
we're in a break thank
you
e
e e
quick update for people who are sitting
here waiting I've just been informed
that we can expect the amendment from OS
in about 10
minutes so we're almost done thanks for
your
patience
e
e e
okay ladies and gentlemen if you could
return to your seats we can get back to
work
okay we are going to
uh continue our executive session on
Senate Bill
451 it has just been delivered to us a
new Amendment
Amendment
H and this
amendment if we turn to page four
lines one two and
three are the new Amendment text that
was just added that text
reads the time to render a decision on
the application May expend may be
extended by the agency of jurisdiction
for good cause upon written request of
the applicant such extensions shall be
reported to the
committee that is the newly added
text the rest of the amend mend m is
identical or should be to the amendment
we reviewed earlier today which was
Amendment
67. yes so this one is 1676
Doh so uh I will move ought to pass as
amended and recognize representative
McGee oh I'll Second That Emotion
it's been moved and seconded and now
I'll recognize representative Corman
introduce this
amendment thank you Mr chairman yes I I
moved the adoption of amendment uh
2024-the representative
Bernardi second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt Amendment
1676 H discuss question on the amendment
as I mentioned a few moments ago the
amendment adds that new text on page
four lines one two and three other than
that is it is identical to the previous
Amendment which we discussed
earlier does anybody have any comments
representative Harrington yeah yeah as I
brought up last week I still think this
thing has got six too many words in it
it says the time to render the decision
on the application may be extended by
the agency of jurisdiction for good
cause should end right there it says
upon written request of the applicant so
if I'm an an agency and I say I can't
get your permit done on time so you must
send in a written request giving me more
time I mean that seems kind of stupid
why do we even bother with the upon
written request of the applicant I'm not
going to hold up the bill on that but I
think I'll be back if I'm back next year
to get rid of that because it makes
absolutely no sense telling the
applicant he must give the the state
agency more time well what's his option
if he says I'm not going to do that then
the agency say well then we don't issue
the permit so I mean it's totally
meaningless well doesn't the Pu process
and the SEC process require written
notice of virtually everything that
happens during the
process to a lot extent yeah but they
could simply say that the department
that will will jur extend it for good
cause and submit written uh notice to
the applicant to let the applicant know
that would make more sense than saying
the applicant has to request a a delay
they don't want just I mean like I say
I'm not going to hold up voting on it
but it's something we should clean up it
should be for good cause and inform the
applicant in writing of the cause and
the delay or the new date or whatever so
that would make more sense seems pretty
proor to
me any further
comments okay good seeing uh none let's
ask the clerk to call the role on the
question of the adoption of amendment
16768 Vice chair Thomas yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Harrington yes representative papovich
Muller yes representative bresney yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Connor yes repres representative Kennedy
yes representative McGee yes
representative MC Williams yes
Representative
crean
no gone uh representative
parshall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Horgan yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes chairman V yes
190 by a vote of 19 to nothing the
committee adopts Amendment 16 76h to
Senate Bill
451 I now move the adoption of uh the
motion of ought to pass as amended and
recognize representative
McGee yes I'd like to second that motion
moved and seconded that we adopt the
motion of ought to pass as amended on
Senate bill
451 any further discussion
needed seeing none soon as he's ready
I'll ask the clerk to call the role on
the question about to pass as
amended Vice shair
Thomas yes representative Melvin yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Pap papovich Muller yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative L yes
representative Connor yes representative
Kennedy yes representative McGee yes
representative McWilliams yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Horgan yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
chairman Vose yes yes
190 by a vote of 19 to zero the
committee adopts the motion of ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill
451 before we conclude our business on
this in this executive session I want to
thank our committee researcher Christy
off fessor
for running over to OS and brow beating
them to get us a new Amendment uh as
promptly as possible we thank you
Christie appreciate you doing that
representative McGee yeah I'd just like
to ask if we could put this on
consent what do you think consent yes
okay everybody says yes so okay we'll
put this on the consent calendar I will
write the committee
report
and I guess that's all we need to do so
with that we'll close that exec session
and before I let you go for the day I
just want you to know that after some
hallway conversations we've settled on
the date of May
14th where the resumption of the
executive session on Senate Bill
595 and in conjunction with that day we
will also have our end of session lunch
at a place to be determined do we have a
time uh to start on May 14th and can it
be not
9 yes we will start on May 14th at 10
o'clock how's that
all right any further business to come
before the committee seeing none we're
adjourned thank you all